Justin Bieber rapping on his Instagram
story and guys it sounds really good
yeah like I said it's great and there's
a ton more the Biebs shared and did you
catch the line about Haley
he says quote my wife yeah I put her on
a pedestal overall he gets pretty candid
in the lyrics he also mentions his
depression which she's been super honest
with his fans about quote they put me on
some medicine and never thought that my
depression would depend on it but sorry
guys the song is not part of Bieber's
new album he made sure to clarify that
writing not album stuff just messing
around while Haley's doing something
video stuff in the otter room it is
tight though many men so at least we
know what the song is called many men
but if you are ready for new jb music he
did promise fans that a new album was
coming very soon during an instagram
live last week this year meaning before
2020
the answer is yes Justin yes and not
only is Justin gearing up for new music
but maybe a new house yeah Justin has
been posting all sorts of pics of his
home on Instagram here writing quote I
think I want to sell my home in Beverly
Hills who wants it and this one quote
I'll sell it with all the furniture make
an offer we also get looks at all sorts
of other things and trinkets in his home
his snowboards a lot of Drew memorabilia
art arcade games and yep look real close
in this shot there's a wine wall a
slushie machine and a foosball table so
basically a dream house no word on when
he hopes to move but we will be sure to
keep you posted on all things Bieber
until next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]